This made me stop and think.
What do you mean, Pixie? No one can lose sympathy
faster
than Pixie.
What does that mean?
Hey, Mike.
like that's like sometime
reading some of these uh messages. I feel like there's like a
like an annoyance or a bitterness
that Trader has
in regards to Pixie.
Like I don't know. Like listen, living with someone is hard.
living working with a friend, someone who's already a friend,
and then you start living with them, that always creates friction.
It's not a good idea typically to live with your friends
um that you've already been friends with or friends, quote unquote.
Uh, it's I find it interesting how Straighter Aid is very like
conscious
of what she lets people know she's aware of when, okay, desperate
tone with words like justice, non-consensual,
and vulnerable showing up for the first time in our messages
almost 2 weeks out from when the original leaks actually happened.
Now here, if you were actually a friend to
if Aaron was a friend to Pixie, she would encourage him uh she
would encourage Pixie to not talk to Destiny at all. Do not because
everything that you say, every message, every public statement,
every private statement
can
and will be used against you by Destiny's
professional
I think it is insane that Aaron has the audacity to think that
she knows
how to
this uh friend and her ability to judge where she's at, if she's
for real or not. That's not how you handle it.
and also this this attitude of like when she said
um let's see.
Yes. Okay. So this when she says probably, but even if I convince
her to not go the route she's currently planning, I consider
that a win, which
a tweet longer and a GoFundMe for legal
So, I don't know what gives Aaron the impression that she
has the judgment or it's any of her business or that it's her
place
to say what is reasonable or not in Pixie's pursuit of justice.
And it will get worse later on when we look at Aaron and Destiny's
DMs.
So, um, I watched through your stream,
um, and I had some some interesting thoughts based on on some
of the things you said. Now, I don't think I don't have like
a
fully fleshed out thoughts on the stream as a whole. Um what
I do is I or what I have is some notes on some sections that
I think that um may or may not they've missed the mark from my
perspective but that doesn't mean that you know you may have
more information. So I have some quotes here and then I'll ask
you questions. Is that okay? Sure.
So, uh, number one,
and we already talked about this, but just to confirm and just
to to, um,
I guess I had sent you the DM, right, about just a knee-jerk
thing because you had said the quotes I have here, the blackmail
angle wouldn't exist without Aaron. The extortion angle wouldn't
exist without Aaron, and this was all made possible by straight
rape. Uh, would you agree
that's not necessarily true? I mean, it could have happened without
and I'm sure if they went down that road, Destiny would probably
claim something of the sort. Yes.
Fair enough. Fair enough. Right. And the way I see it is there
was no extortion that we know of. Um maybe, you know, in a roundabout
way, you could say potentially this this go right. I I could
see it made, but I don't I don't trust Destiny's narrative. No.
So, we would probably agree because he's lying already about
the facts. There's another world where she doesn't bring up money.
He's still going to lie and find. It could have been extortion.
It could have been something else. He's going to find a way to
be the victim, right? Oh, he will find a way to be the victim
no matter what. And I'm sure his
lawyers are are paid plenty to to do that for him.
But, um, the the thing is this timeline though, this is what
happened. So, could uh would Destiny have done everything he
could to go after Pixie? Yes. Did uh Aaron, her friend that she
trusted, make her vulnerable
uh to the person who did this to her? Yes. So, in this timeline,
it didn't have to turn out this way. Um it could have gone it
could have happened all all the same regardless, but in this
timeline, Aaron is
uh why this happened. She was the catalyst. She was the the one
who brought money into the equation.
So, it could have still gone there, but I disagree. She's why
because it's a lie and the only reason it's a narrative is because
Destiny is lie.
The So, you cannot pin that on straight in my opinion.
No, I'm saying that she she uh
Well, I'm not saying that there was extortion or anything. I'm
just saying that she opened uh she made Pixie vulnerable to all
of this.
like she she gave Destiny
uh some tools that he wouldn't have had otherwise. Like it's
best tool.
H but it would have been a different tool, right? He would have
lied anyway because he's lying now. Yeah. And there was an extortion.
He would lie. She's going to lie anyway. Yeah. If it wasn't the
tool of her asking for money, it would have been the tool of
something else. So I don't think we can blame her for that. Um,
I mean, it is the choice she made. Like, someone else could have
made the video that Sunday made, but he's the one that made it.
You know what I mean? Like, someone else could have done it,
but the fact is that it played out a certain way because he's
the one that did it, and here we are now. I couldn't Destiny
is the one who lied about extortion. Aaron didn't try to extort
Destiny. No. So, none of her actions none of it was actually
in the narrative.
In the extortion narrative, no. But she was the one that brought
up money and she's the one that started getting involved, started
telling him to uh um
to offer well she was the one that said to offer to pay for her
therapy, you know, suggested the law school stuff and she was
guiding both of them towards a certain end that she thought was
fair in her own mind when she had no right to
uh no right to get involved in this way.
Okay. So, I think that contradicts one of your other statements,
and I'll kind of move on to that. So, you say that she has no
right to get involved in this way. No. And you also say, "No,
no, hold on." So, I'll build those two points. So, you say she
has no right to get involved that way. But at another point,
you say you're not doing what's best for Pixie. You being straight,
right? So, you say, this is a quote, "You're not doing what's
best for Pixie and asking for what's best for her.
And by doing that, you're saying you're assuming she didn't
um
she didn't do what's right for fixing. I'm sorry. I'm confused
about what you So, I'm saying
Yes. So, you're saying it multiple times? Yeah. I'll repeat it.
So, you say it multiple times that straighter a doesn't do what's
best for Pixie because doing what's best for Pixie is hearing
her out and then following her requests, right? Do you with me
so far? Um, following her requests, not directly, but like being
concerned with like her needs and her well-being.
Agreed. Fair enough. But you're assuming that she's not because
you don't have their DMs, right? That she's not looking out for
Pixie. She's literally sharing the private DMs with Destiny.
Right. She shared part of them, right? But not Did she? I don't
think she shared all of them, right? And that we would hope that
it's her best friend that she is in some way or in probably in
a large way doing what she thinks is best because I think we
both can agree that Pixie is largely impotent. So she doesn't
she's not a good advocate for herself. But why is that
place? Because first of all, Aaron has shown that she does not
have the understanding or judgment like especially when it comes
to the not having good judgment is different. Not not having
good judgment is different than whether Pixie asked Straight
Aid or not to do this to to advocate for them. Oh, are you saying
that she might have asked Straight Aid to mediate between
Well, so Straight Aid is already being entrusted with this information
in a very small circle. Correct. Only like one or two people
know about this.
Well, no. She She told some other people
Aaron or Pixie? Aaron.
Or unless you're saying Pixie. Oh, Pixie. Pixie trusted straight
on. Yes. Yes. Yes. So Pixie has the entire weight of basically
what is what we believe to be her friend's life on her shoulders.
You mean uh Aaron does?
Aaron does. Yes. Yeah.
So, and at another point you say, so Straight A is talking to
President Sunday in DMs
and she says that she feels overwhelmed by this. Uhhuh. And you
say, quote, you feel overwhelmed by being in Pixie's limited
support network. If you don't know, get help. Meaning, if you
don't know how to help, get help. And that you
feel overwhelmed.
You think that the solution was destiny?
I'm not saying she made a good decision, but you said that being
overwhelmed in and of itself
was you you said it was a bad thing to even say to her friend,
President Sunday. No, I think that it was um that that was one
of multiple things that she said that made me like raise my eyebrow
because it's it's the because of the focus like that and like
when she said that like you know no one can uh
uh
um no one can lose sympathy as fast as Pixie, something to that
effect. Like just little comments that made me feel that's true.
How is that true? Pixie is like the perfect victim. I don't really
understand how that works. I'll explain. Uh-huh. Right. So, I
understand she is the perfect victim. Have you ever read her
Twitter?
How have what? What do you have you ever read Have you ever read
her Twitter account?
Well, oh, you mean in general? I don't look at Twitter.
Have you ever read her Twitter account, tweets? Anything?
uh just the ones that were shown here.
I'll just say there's not a single time
there's there's not a yes there and that's a regular occurrence.
It's even mentioned by everyone in this case that she's not mentally
well causing more
that's true but she also garners while while I agree she is in
a many ways the perfect victim she at the same time can garner
a lot of she says things that maybe are a little silly so that
doesn't make her a bad person or even a bad victim right but
she does say things with uh she she will take trolls seriously
for instance Yeah. And she brings a lot of attention to herself,
she doesn't really want, right? She will fight with trolls. Mhm.
Right. So when she says she loses that sympathy on her own, that's
not a false statement. What she's saying is that from my read
that again, Straighter is a very direct person. But this is Twitter.
So she may
like what who cares about Twitter? Like all of this is not going
to take place on Twitter. This is going to take place in court.
This is not Is the statement incorrect?
Huh? Wait, which statement is is is the statement from straight
red? So when Pixie posts her Substack
and when Pixie talks on Twitter about both the case because that's
where she where she communicates everything about the case and
you're saying it doesn't matter. Um but it it is true straighter
what Strader is saying is largely true. Now, I'm not she I'm
saying that Pixie because she is a perfect victim, Destiny takes
advantage of perfect victims, right? So, because of that, because
Pixie is very innocent in a sharkinfested pool like DGG,
it's very easy for Destiny to take advantage of that and for
Pixie to walk into a couple traps. Yes, but again, that doesn't
make her a bad person, right? It doesn't. But that has nothing
to do like this is so much larger than just meating
people. Wait, when you're advocating for Pixie, if Pixie is going
to walk into traps, you're going to have to have some tough conversations
about helping her avoid those traps. And that may involve, especially
if you're confiding in a friend, talking about how she walks
into those traps, which is what I read is being said. I Here's
the thing. I think um you know at some point uh Pixie stopped
talking to Aaron which was the smart move obviously since she
was like leaking stuff all over the place to people. Um I think
that
uh maybe this is a little like
of a uh hyperfocused perspective on the the optics of engaging
in these spaces when it's not about engaging in these spaces.
It's it's like it is but it's also separate like we are not going
to determine the outcome of her case
like that's for a judge. So, I don't like I think that what you
would do as a friend, support your your friend, right? But like
you shouldn't be trying to maneuver her into some like what if
your friend doesn't advocate for themselves and they hurt themselves
in the first place? Would you not be advocating for them by helping
them avoid those traps? No. No. You You don't take away someone's
That's factually wrong. That's factually wrong. You if somebody
wrong. Not even a fact that you can say that's just my opinion.
I'm okay. I'm giving my opinion that it's factually wrong. This
is a contradiction. But so you're saying you're saying so if
somebody is on the ledge, you're not going to try to save your
friend because you know they're maybe in not the best mental
state. You're going to say if you want to jump, go for it. You
no
wishes to take a bunch of
that is that's what was happening with like
what you just said. That is not what I said. Okay, let's let's
uh take it. That is the logical conclusion. Go ahead. It's not
the logical conclusion because what they ended up doing was actually
um
one of the worst worst ways that you could handle it, which is
dismissing her actually being
and not getting a wellness check on her, not trying to make sure
she's physically just strictly advocating for her word for word.
You're saying what she asked for. If you are right advocating
for what she asked for, but if she's advocating to jump off her
roof, the logical conclusion is you would not contradict that,
right? When you know that's not true. Why are you say you I Okay,
this is getting into uh it's not an all orno thing. Obviously,
what I'm saying is that if you were a friend, you would try to
uh support them, listen to them, you and also understand that
you
love someone, right? But you she Okay, so Aaron's idea of what
best for Pixie was cuz she also said that she would um
that if she Okay. All right. This is what she said in that same
um that same DM. Okay. Um when they were saying
uh
President Sunday said, "Pixie is really dumb. You and I have
to assume that if we deal with her straightly, she will make
a very stupid decision." Trader said probably. But even if I
convince her to not go the route she's currently planning, I
consider that a win. Right now she's thinking of a Twit longer
and GoFundMe for legal fees. While I do think some people hate
Steven enough to open their wallet and donate what to what could
be a legal headache, I don't think it's a good idea because of
how Pixie is uh because of how Pixie is. No one can lose sympathy
faster than her and Keles's poison people's ability to fund raise
for stuff like that. So this is just pure speculation.
This is just like uh in in Straighter Aid's like hypothetical
world that she thinks would be an ideal outcome. You're saying
don't speculate with pri in private with your friends and DMs.
Come on. No. Her her saying here
that she is trying to convince her to not go down the route that
she's currently going right now. What's Pixie's number one wish?
You should know the answer to this. What's her number one wish?
that this never
This all stays private.
Right now, she's uh she also said in a threeear court case is
the opposite of private. Nope. Nope. Nope. Wait, this is what
Wait, what part do you disagree? Would What part do you disagree
with before you continue that? That's not her number one wish.
No, I'm looking where where is it?
Hold on. Let me Can I get Can you tell me what you disagree with?
No, I'm I'm looking for something. I'm looking for the exact
thing. Um
Why is she going to kill herself? I She's going to kill herself
if her parents find out, right?
Which means she wants it to stay private. Yes, of course she
wanted it. She wanted people to not know, but then also in a
three-year court battle is the opposite of private. So, she's
really advocating for Pixie special wishes there. So, January
1st, Straighter Aid says, "Pixie wants to go public before the
end of January, and I don't know what to tell her because there's
pros and cons both ways."
What What you got to You got to make a statement. I didn't
It sounds like that wasn't the
main thing that she wanted, was it to just say there was no keeping
it private
was why was she going to kill herself if her parents found out?
I mean, she wanted to keep it as private as possible. She did
not want to go public with this cuz she was telling people that
she wasn't in the weeks, wasn't she? Yeah, she was. She was crashing
So, what should Straighter Aid's number one goal be? If you if
I take your word for it that she should advocate
wishes, she should not be going to Destiny and telling him about
her vulnerable financial financial situation.
I don't disagree with that. Right. Okay. What you're what you're
what you're doing is is that I can say that I can both at the
same time say that was a bad choice. And also straight away thought
she was advocating for her friend and didn't think that Destiny
was the devil at the time.
At the same time, then she's I don't know what to say about that.
Like this is not her place. This is not um her idea. what her
friend is asking for you. So when you say it's not her place,
you're contradicting yourself. Did she ask her if um she she
didn't she ask Ka? Pixie was Pixie thought Kyla was good to talk
to. Pixie said to Kya to go talk to Destiny because Destiny wasn't
hearing you out. So even it could be advocating for what she's
saying for what she wants and Pixie can be.
Yes. But that is that's still her uh that's still her. So that's
a contradiction. So you're saying that straight a can you're
saying straight a raid should follow what Pixie's wishes generally?
No. But now Straight Arid.
I'm not saying that roughly. No, she should be supporting her
friend in a way. You already trying to choreograph
the way things work out. You said you agreed earlier.
You agreed many times. You said it many times and you agreed
earlier with the characterization that I said that she should
advocate for Pixie's wishes as she wishes them largely or broadly
or
advocate for Pixie as you're going to the next point. Just say
yes or no. Just say yes or no and then and then I can make that
because what I'm saying is
you agreed earlier Uh-huh. You agreed earlier Uh-huh. that straight
away should advocate for what Pixie's wishes are and not think
for Pixie. Correct.
Um, did I say advocate?
Roughly. I'm I'm trying to characterize a because No, no, because
the word advocate is different. Um, cuz when I'm saying when
I'm saying that she should support her friend, I'm not saying
that she should take an active role in trying to work it out
for her. She does this. She doesn't have the the knowledge the
uh what if that's her wishes? What if that's her wishes? Then
she could then Pixie could say so. Oh, I wanted Aaron to do all
of this. Well, but you don't but you don't but you don't know
that that didn't happen because what Aaron can say that it happened.
I don't know.
The logic frame that I'm walking you down Uhhuh. is that Pixie
wanted all this private. She didn't want her parents to to find
out. Yes. So by pushing her by uh talking to President Sundai
and talking about how the lawsuit might not be a good way and
that getting some amount of money for law school maybe Pixie's
wishes because she wants this all to stay private and she probably
would want even if it's dumb. You're condemning Straight Raid
for being dumb but she could be following Pixie's wishes. Okay.
So, are you saying that there it could be the case that Pixie
was the one who initially wanted the money and Straighter Raid
was the vehicle? Not specifically the money. Not specifically
the money. Right. So, like let's say Pixie says to Strader, I
want all this private that's that's what I want. And then straight
is now talking to President Sunday kind of brainstorming or even
by herself she's thinking how can I get something for Pixie so
she feels a bit better but I follow her wishes of keeping this
not I mean meaning meaning not lawsuit public so she probably
the logical conclusion
would be getting money from Destiny and private
correct I don't think that's the logical next step
the the whole You can say it's you can say it's illogical, but
it it does follow the logic train that it would be Pixie's best
wish. What she wants. I have no I have nothing to show that.
There's no reason for me to think this. Like it could I mean
there's no
evidence for me to go
off of that there was some other No, I didn't make up a narrative.
I'm going literally based off of what the You said the blackmail
angle wouldn't exist without Aaron and that she's not looking
out for Pixie's best wishes. But I gave you I gave you an alternative
narrative and you've already made a narrative, but I've just
poked a hole in your narrative. So all I'm saying is you could
you are incorrect.
I don't know. I still don't understand. What do you mean you
poked a hole in my narrative? My narrative is that a Aaron should
not have taken it upon herself to go and tell Destiny all of
these things about Pixie and tell him her vulnerabilities
and to these things to other people.
I don't disagree with that. Doesn't make I'm I've given you multiple
reasons why that doesn't make her evil. And I was specifically
talking about the quote you made. I wasn't talking. Well, you
said the blackmail angle wouldn't exist exist without Aaron and
Aaron is not looking out for Pixie or her best wishes. And you
said she was being selfish and she was it was uh she you said
feeling overwhelmed was unreasonable.
No, I I being overwhelmed and and complaining about being overwhelmed
is uh like being focused on your overwhelm. friend might themselves.
You can't even mention to a friend in private that you're feeling
overwhelmed is is what you just said and said early and I think
that's I will sure maybe I was being too harsh there. Okay, I'll
I'll Fair enough. I'm sorry I was aggressive. I'm sorry I was
aggressive. I I could believe she's overwhelmed. Doesn't know
how to handle it. Yeah, I agree.
That's fair. That's fair. Okay.
other thoughts on what I said or
um I mean that's kind of
like I said this is just what
this is what happened in this timeline like because straight
raid is the catalyst for this happening like this is just how
it could have played out a million different ways this is how
it played out here and uh yeah I think that it's having
um thinking that you are able like like the thing that uh Sunday
and Straighter are doing here. I completely disagree with this
entire plot. You should be communicating with the person that's
hurt. You should be working with them and let them make their
own decisions. You're saying don't confide in a friend about
what to do and to help them out when she's overwhelmed. That's
a I think that's a I'm not saying to go to Destiny. they are
plotting together like when they're strateg they're they're coming
up with strategies like particularly
uh straighter aid when she's saying that she want like when she's
talking to both both Pixie and Destin Destiny privately trying
to coordinate this kind of uh settling based on the therapy potentially
law school trying to work that out um
that's that's but that could be in Pixie's wishes Right.
I mean, it could, but also why would she be saying that she has
to talk her out of this
Because Pixie has two things on her mind. She is because Pixie
is overwhelmed and making, as you've admitted and agreed, poor
decisions. Yes. Including on Twitter, right? Yes. So, Pixie has
a scatterbrain. We agree. Roughly. Now, if Pixie says a lot of
things, but she also says, "My number one priority is keeping
this private,"
you do have to agree arranging some private payment might be
the best thing for what Pixie wants. Not Not arranging private
payment on someone else's behalf and not over something like
this where you could actually have legal recourse. I think it's
wildly irresponsible.
That doesn't disagree with anything I
What do you It could be in Pixie's wishes to arrange payment
and if you suggested because you know that is what
if she requested that from Aaron
then that would be different.
Why did she have to request it from Aaron? If Pixie scatter
crazy things. Are you saying she's too
Okay, hold on. Just It's going to be her decision in the end.
It's Pixie doesn't she's not saying yes on behalf of Pixie. She's
giving that idea to Destiny to just offer it up for Pixie to
make the final decision. And she she g she approved his message
and to Pixie and the presentation because Pixie is in a state.
Yes, we can see in retrospect it's very e hold. It's very easy
for us to say yes, obviously Destiny is evil, right? But when
this person has been your friend and I'm sure Aaron still saw
him as a friend and didn't and you know what else on top of this
to that point we don't know
that how much Aaron thought Destiny was at fault in this and
how evil he truly was because the narrative that he was also
pushing and still does is that none of this was his fault and
it was a the hacker, right? And if Aaron even buys that 10% and
she sees this person who's who's done her friend wrong, but still
doesn't see Destiny's evil just yet, it is totally reasonable
to have a not a perfect set of decision making. And you she's
overwhelmed, she said. And she's leaning on what she thinks is
a friend, Destiny. Yes, in retrospect, a dumb decision. But the
malice you put on her, I think, is I didn't put malice. No, no,
no. chat. There was chat and and
uh yeah, chat was saying I didn't say that there was malice.
I said that this feels very
strange and uh unempathetic.
I didn't say malice like she was trying to do something bad to
Pixie or her over
You just say she's taking away what? So, so, so you believe that
she's
so, so you believe all all of this wasn't in malice, but when
someone brought like autism, you said
um that no, she was she's she's not, you know, or whatever, and
it doesn't take away empathy, right? I said that autism and empathy
are not mutually exclusive. So, like picking up social cues is
one thing, but like having empathy and and knowing like um
having having a sense of like how to help your friend that's
not attached to
Okay. So, I don't have to just to be fair to you, I don't have
anything in my notes here. I got the vibe that you were attributing
now. I'll just give you the charity that you're saying that she
was acting extremely recklessly. Is that fair tock what you were
saying? Recklessly. And I understand she like I'm not saying
that Shrader Raid should go away. Just saying that this is like
has to be dealt with cuz otherwise it's just going to be super
weird and later on it's going to be an even bigger thing. So
she literally could just say like, "Yeah, I was overwhelmed and
it was reckless and I didn't know Destiny was evil at the time."
And that would make sense.
Well, you have I think that's fair. I think you have to assume
all of those things. You I don't need to assume any of them because
I don't really like I Well, you can't say it's not malice and
she's I didn't say that it's not malice. I I didn't call it malice.
I don't I don't know. So, you don't know. I'm not suggesting
that it is. I'm just not claiming anything about
Like the whole thing is my issue is her trying to corral
people into like what she thought was going to be the best outcome
for the situation when she had no
uh no right to and no ability to you know what I mean like I'm
it was reckless like you said. So, if she said I was reckless,
I didn't know he was evil and I was overwhelmed and I did uh
you know what I did was stupid. Like if she said that, that would
be fine. Okay. So,
fair enough. So, I think that the the contradiction I think lies
in if as you just said, you think she's acting in the best outcome
for the situation. So, you think she's advocating for Pixie
that would be her going about things,
huh? without mouths. Wait, I'm sorry.
If you agree with me roughly, it's just my hypothesis that you
think that she is doing the best outcome for the situation,
which is what you just said, right? In quotes. Um,
no, I'm not I'm not thinking of okay,
best for the situation. what she thinks is best for the situation
as a whole, not necessarily Pixie.
Gotcha.
Because if she was solely supporting Pixie, it would look very
differently. She wouldn't be doing all this negotiation. But
like you said, if she thought it was an accident, she didn't
think that he was evil or whatever, I can understand. I can see
how this played out. But she's regardless, she's still not acting
in Pixie's best interest like solely.
doctor. So, you think that she's making
she's not by not advocate.
Okay. I feel like I I missed a contradiction. I might have been
confused there. But, um what I'll do is is that, you know, I
don't have anything else here in my notes. Um so, you know, maybe
I'll hit you up tomorrow after I listen back to this and maybe
I miss something if that's okay with you. But I think we'll fine
unless you have questions for me. Um, I think one more thing
I would say is that like just because an adult is is crashing
out and doing things that you think might be bad for them, if
you care about them like and it's not about any like the larger
situation, if your greatest concern is their immediate well-being,
you would uh not be trying to control them because you can't
you can't control someone like that. You can only like you have
to
they they might re she try to control Pixie.
Oh, I don't mean like in a
in directly trying to control her. I mean like try if you try
to help someone by telling them don't go on Twitter, don't do
this or that. Like when people are crashing out, they might just
like do it anyway. You know what I mean? Like they don't necessarily
they're not acting rationally necessarily. Um,
so
I don't know if that makes sense, but what I'm saying is that
she's still an adult. Pixie is still an adult and ultimately
whatever like happens, I think should be concerned about her
imminent potential. I think that was probably the greatest risk.
That's pretty. I think we can agree to disagree there and I'll
leave it there and I appreciate you taking my call. Of course.
All right. I'll talk to you later, Ryle.
Bye. Take it easy. Bye-bye.
Okay,
I'm back.